up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to some hate tick tocks
on me I know you guys are shocked but at
times people don't like the things that
I say and they make videos about it this
was news to me until my producer
blessing decided to put me together a
compilation before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in and leave
a comment and let me know what you guys
think and to everyone calling me a pick
me I'd rather be a pick me than a skip
me yeah okay
poem I know okay where the hell did Skip
me just punch pick me in the face oh wow
she seems lovely honestly I'm sure I'm
sure she'll get picked
which one of you
decided to call my mother
yeah
yeah that was that was that was too far
internet that was too far a t-shirt
dress is very very ambitious considering
that you're going all over the Internet
talking about other people's bodies
I would I would have thought that your
body would snatched to the point where
they were placing you I'll tell you what
it's not 300 pounds 300 pounds that's a
lie back of milk cartons
no
no all right then it's like okay this is
this is the Mad thing when these people
that are body positive body positive you
say something they don't like what's the
first thing they do go for your body I
thought you weren't I thought you were
body positive over here
guess not you know I know it's
disappointing when you lose a whole
bunch of weight and you still realize
that you're a terrible person
it's unfortunate isn't it
that you're still basic you lost all
this weight because and you thought that
your life was going to turn around no
I'm still basic I'm just smaller
so you have to make up for it with a
huge look if I'm basic now then I was
negative basic when I was fat because
that's the thing these people think they
could just insult me what did I say that
was incorrect do men like fat chicks no
no like it's like they don't have a good
argument so they just call you ugly I'm
like can you be a little bit more
creative with your insults it's just
lame shitty personality congratulations
you won
y'all can we just stop living in
delusion oh
point to stay at a white folks business
I have been seeing this girl all over
Tick Tock and I don't understand how you
can look like a crusty leftover grilled
cheese sandwich
I've got to be I didn't shoot at anyone
I said no one looks good at 300 pounds
and you're like negative 21. you don't
have lips but what you do seem to have
is the [ __ ] audacity I have seen you
in a long tight dress and all I have to
say is Zoe you look like Zoe from the
proud family and I think even that may
be too much of a compliment seen as
though Zoe does look like a teenager
you're in your 20s and you look like
you're 44. also any one of these bad
[ __ ] I'm about to show will eat you
the [ __ ] up all right Kobe smash or pass
so the past smash your past this girl
pass
girl smash or pass
[Music]
look at her yeah you could never smash
or pass
even my mommy called me it's such a
waste honestly those girls are still
kind of cute that big it's a waste you
were born beautiful beautiful and and
you're getting fat why I lost a bunch of
weight I'm still not good enough for her
so I need to externally [ __ ] on other
people now here's the thing I just tell
the world how it is I don't make the
rules men don't like fat chicks show me
someone but watch I I guarantee 90 of
these they're just calling me ugly
that's their go-to she's ugly she's ugly
because you don't have a better argument
you know I'm right and so what's your
immediate response you're ugly it looks
good at 300 or or you need therapy
that's number two it always goes okay
you're ugly you need therapy you're
insecure and your personality so it's
like the argument they never can attack
y'all are just proving my point ever
since I'd seen someone say this [ __ ]
looks like her eyes are upside down
that's all I can see
oh my god with so much confidence too
I strive to have our confidence because
she'd be talking but it sounds
interesting now I'm confident but the
other ones say I'm insecure that and
very loudly for
no reason mom you pick me
I'd rather be to pick me than a skip me
alternatively I feel like me and this
girl could be sisters
do you see it I feel like we could be
like a distant cousin I would rather be
skipped over
every day of the year
for the next hundred years
and die in my apartment by myself with
my cat and have my cat eat my dead
corpse
before I would want these [ __ ]
terrible men to pick me you seem like
you'd have a long happy marriage
I was I thought 200 pounds
and I knew I didn't look good not by my
I was like 205 too I'm just saying it
wasn't by that much it wasn't everyone's
acting like oh you you lost like a
stupid amount I did but I'm pretty tall
I wasn't I wasn't that fat baby you
can't brand yourself as a motivational
speaker if the source of your motivation
and Enlightenment comes from self-hatred
because let me tell you something now
yeah see it's another you're insecure
it's another one all hatred right there
is palpable we see this hey I just hate
myself I have a horrible life
every few months right somebody comes
out of the shadows and decides to put on
a caricature of like the most ridiculous
and hated yeah just so yeah I hate
myself and that they can think of in
order to get engagement attention likes
and they think it's gonna translate into
money however it never works out in the
long term for them baby you are not
special you are regular average and
quite frankly uninteresting the word but
see this is a modern woman being regular
at average is not an insult most people
are average but modern women think
they're special thank you for proving my
point Thank you for proving my point and
as a woman who has a brand a career and
music based off of women empowerment
because I am an empowered woman it is
very sad to me that you are gonna
sacrifice what a great legacy you could
have had to something so brittle because
let's be honest you're just the new
hated Trend no one will care about you
in a month yeah yeah like a month since
like we did this video no one cares
about me yeah 80 million views this
month baby
baby yeah yeah you're right I'm I'll be
gone tomorrow ha ha
hey bestie it's the whale from that
video I wanna have a little chit chat
with you she started it she made a video
calling me ugly basically and so I just
did a video do wedding her being like
I'm not saying anything and then she was
like the the trend was basically saying
that I was the ugly one and she was the
hot one and I'm like
yeah yeah
because I woke up to like a hundred
thousand reviews on my video and
hundreds of comments of your little boy
Army commenting how fat I am which is
honestly kind of funny the fact that
we're in the year 2022 and y'all still
think the word fat is gonna like send me
into a spiral like nah I didn't say fat
it's a description word I know I'm fat
what like get a little bit more original
but that's not the point of this and I
know I know that you live for male
validation and you need to project your
insecurities out into other people so
these men can like give you that
attention you need and I'm happily
married you know I have someone that
admires and adores me so I know that you
need it more than I do so I'm happy to
take that bullet for you I'm all about
girls supporting girls so you can say
I'm happy for you I hope I hope you have
a great marriage I hope I'm just okay I
don't know if I should say I'm gonna say
it if you're overweight you're gonna
have health problems eventually and
who's got to take care of you your
husband so I hope to God have a happy
marriage I hope you have a happy life I
got nothing against you but being
overweight is going to cause you issues
down the line whether it's tomorrow next
week next year next month whatever it is
there are going to be issues that come
with being overweight and saying I'm
fine the way I am I'm beautiful the way
I am it sounds nice but who's gonna take
care of you so everyone else has to deal
with your inability to lack discipline
and self-control little boys on Tick
Tock over to comment how fat I am
because you need that attention but
that's not the point of this video
point of this video so that I hope that
I can
bring someone awareness to you of how
cruel some of your words can be
especially to younger people because
deep down I really want to believe that
somewhere in your little tiny Grinch
heart
that there is some kindness in you
I'm doubtful but I'm also that's why I'm
making this I hope I can get across to
you just a little bit and it's not the
fact that you're saying 300 pound people
aren't attractive that's your opinion
it's wrong but that's whatever I know
I'm hot and I know
hahaha
okay and I know I'm beautiful and you
and your little boys that comment are
never gonna take that away from me and I
know that's gonna drive you absolutely
crazy oh yeah I'm gonna lose so much
sleep tonight yeah it's just gonna drive
me nuts but it's not so sorry
the thing though that it sent me is when
you said 300 pound people don't deserve
love which no no no no no no I said
nobody deserves love like the whole
point the whole point is people think
that they are entitled to things and
women think they are entitled to love
men aren't that delusional I said you
don't deserve a man that makes six
figures if you're 300 pounds guys that
make six figures tend to date thin women
they tend to date the most beautiful
attractive women on the planet I don't
think I am entitled to dating a man that
makes six figures but for some reason
chicks think they are that's like a
broke bum saying I deserve I don't even
want to say Victoria's Secret model
because they look different nowadays but
like a supermodel
I deserve Beyonce you would look at him
like he's insane for some reason chicks
think they can do this so cruel and
cold-hearted because every single person
is crying am I tripping does she sound
like she's crying even you
and the fact that you're saying that
like now you have to earn it you have to
earn it you have to be someone that
earns love you don't just deserve it the
only one that deserves love are children
imagine a 12 year old coming across the
video that you said that that might be
struggling with their body or not even
overweight but you know they're young
who knows and they start to believe that
and they start to believe they have to
do anything they possibly can become
skinny and to prove it to you and not
prove it to themselves that they have to
look a certain way to be loved that's
going to create Eating Disorders body
dysmorphia mental health issues all in
these young people or even people that
don't have the self-love and confidence
in themselves that they truly start to
believe those words
and that's so [ __ ] up that's so [ __ ]
up and the fact that you get on a
podcast and you like say these things
and intentionally bully other people
because you're so insecure within
yourself
it blows my mind it's not bullying I'm
just telling you what the world is and
you cannot like it you cannot like the
truth but it doesn't change the world
and honestly if there is a child that's
overweight that's on the parents that's
on the pair you should not allow your
child to be overweight and that's a
crazy thing this is another reason why
being fat translates to problems for
other people like one of the reasons
that I wanted to get my eating and my
weight under control is because I want
to have children and you don't want to
pass on your horrible habits to your
kids and now becomes their problem and I
really hope you grow out of this bully
phase because it's not cute so I'm going
to continue to spread fat positivity oh
no of course that positivity if that
positive photographer and make people
feel beautiful and show that okay but do
You Hear What cheesy says and this is
they tell on themselves with the words
they use feel beautiful not look
beautiful I don't make women look
beautiful I make them feel beautiful
Because deep down they know they're not
they know they're not supposed to look
like that and they know a lot of them
it's a waste of a pretty face everyone
is worthy to be loved no matter what you
look like
so I hope you figure that out and I hope
you grow this face because it's not cute
but
go off
people are roasting that fat phobic girl
all over my for you page today and she's
acting so unbothered but like keeps
responding to everything and I just know
I know for a fact that tonight she is
going to cry herself to sleep
filled with self-hatred I am someone
that looks good at 300 pounds 300 pounds
isn't healthy it doesn't look
as someone who weighs 300 pounds I kind
of take offense to that I guess maybe
you shouldn't make generalizations about
everybody because I think I look good at
300 pounds yeah
sorry
I was I've been over 200 pounds
and I knew I didn't look good and so
sweetheart did you ever think that oh no
oh no then you didn't look good at 200
pounds is because you just don't look
good in general is that a really mean
thing to say yes do I mean it yes this
girl has been all over this app for the
past month or so saying some of the most
fat phobic disgusting [ __ ] I have ever
heard I am absolutely not shocked to
find out that this girl used to be 200
pounds or used to be fat because X I
never hit 300.
I never hit 300. people are usually some
of the worst perpetrators of fat phobia
yeah because I
pull no there's no EX
and you're just
spam poor choices because they never
learn to love themselves they never got
over that internalized no no I think
losing weight is the ultimate form of
self-love what is better for you than
losing weight and getting in good shape
they just change their body and that's
it in my experience it's always crusty
girls like this that say oh my God how
do all these fat girls have boyfriends
and I'm single and alone because you're
a miserable [ __ ] and that's ugly inside
and out no no I could tell you why all
these girls have boyfriends there's a
simp epidemic but we're done men are
gonna start walking away walking away
just wait nah they probably won't
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that looks good at 300 pounds she
supports my harassment how rude her
pounds isn't healthy it doesn't look
good did you know that instead of
antagonizing fat people
when it's the guys they always have like
a a voice uh that's like two octaves too
high you can go online right now and get
some Ube extract and make your own Ube
ice cream at home that's a vivid purple
and gorgeous flavor what a wonderful way
to spend your time instead is it good
I mean if it's good maybe not shaming
it's just being honest and we live in
this world where you cannot be honest
five rapid fire responses coming your
way one what do you mean you can't were
you arrested are you in jail did you
receive a monitor no but you guys
harassed my mother my mother like that's
pretty far and my siblings fine you can
say whatever you want evidenced by the
fact that you won't shut the [ __ ] up and
I'd do it again pull our allowed to
respond two there's a difference between
being honest and being mean I cannot
imagine that this is how you address
friends or family members if so Props
for consistency but honesty without
compassion anywhere is just you being a
dick third you're so wrapped up in what
you can and can't say that you never
stop to think should I I'll answer it
for you you shouldn't people think mean
why would I listen to you that's a crazy
thing like modern women modern women are
narcissists you're gonna tell me how to
do a podcast where's your podcast
like that's oh my gosh it's not even
just her but these women there's even
YouTubers I'm not gonna name names but
there's some in London these YouTubers
tick-tockers podcasters that will be
like I don't like your tone I don't like
this I don't like that and it's like
that you do it if you could do it better
then go do it oh wait you don't okay my
whole point is this the audacity of
modern women it's like if I went to an
NBA coach or NFL player and told him how
to play even though I've never played
football all the time but they are no
longer Elementary schoolers who are
struggling with the concept of what is
and isn't appropriate to say out loud
just
keep that to yourself number four enough
is she saying as a woman I should keep
my opinions to myself
the blatant sexism that I experience
every day wow wow missed in elementary
school opinions are not facts you
sharing your shitty opinion does not
mean that you're being honest yeah men
love girls at 300 pounds you're right
that's that's an opinion
there's no Trend at all it just means I
see so many rich men with fat chicks
being the worst first and lastly she
kind of hit that note life is short why
spend your time making other people feel
bad is it because your life I can't help
control how you feel I can't control how
you feel if you feel bad because you see
my content that's on you that is 100 on
you if me saying 300 pounds is a lot and
that's fat and men don't like that and
it hits because you're close you're 300
pounds are close to it that's on you
that's not my fault it's not my fault
that you got if you think that I'm lying
if you think that I'm not telling the
truth then it wouldn't bother you why do
you think that half of this [ __ ] doesn't
bother me because I know you guys are
just making [ __ ] up because you're
offended but you're triggered because
you know what I am saying is true or sad
and embarrassing I thought so they had
for a man to court them for a man to
treat them like a princess because they
actually deserved it but women today we
don't deserve it because we're older and
we don't have the things that men value
we're not pure we're not submissive we
don't cook we don't you know know how to
take care of a family I just find that
doesn't mean you're a bad person but if
you're going into the market again this
is just an analogy as a used Honda Civic
and asking for new BMW prices you're not
going to have a lot of takers and if you
do have a taker he's going to be a fool
and are you really going to want that
fool can somebody just take one for the
team and pick her so she can stop making
these videos
[Music]
it is astounding and
I'm speechless I don't know
that's it the self-hatred it's just
another version of she's insecure blah
blah blah everyone
that is using my sound where I said show
me someone that looks good at 300 pounds
my point that's all I gotta say you're
just I was scrolling on Tick Tock and I
saw your face
I heard your picture plus size women all
over your space
okay the problem is I don't know what
Cafe means you have I don't know what
that means I I feel like I'm being
insulted but I don't know
unattractive
[Music]
yeah it sucks and we shoot in 4k baby I
liked that song I I inspired a song name
someone that looks good at 300 pounds
300 pounds isn't healthy well since you
asked
Hearn you see what I'm saying the voice
is like two octaves too high it's a
trend my name is Hannah Sada that's my
girlfriend oh gosh
oh gosh
please don't make me say it
please don't do this to me
[Music]
look how pretty she is look at that look
at that smile little cheeks and her eyes
look at their sparkling
and that smile
she also got that juice look at that
booty
yeah okay but the prettiest thing of all
her smile which is really the isn't it
interesting how he didn't say her baby
reason behind why I'm doing this I
really don't care
things as far as this goes this is
purely to make that girl smile you'll
never be able to convince me that that
girl's not gorgeous
you know what makes her look really
really good
oh no she's pretty Unapologetic
you can call me I want to make sure you
put killer in front of them about being
fat
and the confidence
on her to be herself and
do you think he's are we thinking the
same thing I can't say things
individually okay we I don't have to say
it I don't have to say it's like if you
want to call her well make sure you put
killer in front of it because she's
awesome
it's girls like her that make you so
angry
you hate to see fat girls love
themselves
you hate it for some reason I don't know
why
but
that's one of the things about her that
makes her gorgeous it's the reason I
fell in love with her to begin with
see we met through Tick Tock the
algorithm said
for you she's for you the algorithm was
very correct
I will not make any assumptions about
this man's preferences
but they just seem to be uh that's all
I'm gonna say it is a little more
popular than you though because she's
like a really good person and tries to
be positive and lift other women up who
are normally dragged down by Society
I don't think as many people agree with
you as you think
the correction my old account had 850
000 they took that that 50k was in
like a week or two weeks I'm at 70 now
and I barely post on that thing it's
it's not hard to get followers on Tick
Tock it's actually pretty easy and if
you didn't care what people think you
wouldn't allow these videos to keep
being stitched you wouldn't even comment
on being fat because the feelings you
have about being fat come from your own
insecurities
it's so obvious 300 pounds is a lot I'm
just gonna keep saying this
300 is a lot
me what I weigh does not change the fact
that men don't like fat chicks
now there are exceptions but typically
those exceptions don't
seem to have a lot of options
I'm not saying anything about you
personally but
when we take in to account guys with the
most options
they tend to date thin beautiful women
I don't I don't make the rules I just
tell you what they are insecurities that
if you were honest with yourself have
nothing to do with health but all to do
with how you're treated
how you were treated
but anyways back to the topic of the
video uh name somebody who looks good at
300 pounds
showed me
tell them you lose weight it's not
healthy you're not healthy at that size
and oh [ __ ] did you hear what she's
saying she's saying that people around
300 pounds are really unhealthy and
should lose weight
oh man that sounds pretty serious
yeah we should probably listen to her
because she's probably a doctor or
something oh my God I hate this argument
it's so stupid
do I need a doctor's degree to see when
you broke your leg that something's
wrong I don't need a doctor's degree or
a nutritionist degree or any of that to
tell you that 300 pounds is a lot and
you're probably not eating right you're
probably not eat right
um no actually according to her LinkedIn
she's worked as a YouTube podcaster for
the past two years
okay got it well you know maybe she's
like worked in healthcare or something
like that
um no actually uh but she's been in uh
business and like marketing and stuff
like that sales
got it got it
that makes sense
so by now you've seen some of her work
ah bad [ __ ] stating her opinions is
facts plus those people don't look good
in things plus size people can't be
pretty plus-sized people can't be
anything it's just a fact no it's not
300 is a lot I didn't say any plus size
I've seen some girls that are plus size
and cute
but at 300 I'm sorry I I've yet to see
it it's your opinion and here's my
opinion
you got dumped and it hurts and you're
trying to release that hurt but making
people on the internet feel like [ __ ] so
they can join you in your pool of Sorrow
is not how we do things if this is your
reaction to a bump in your road it's
indicative of why your relationship
didn't see and that's the thing they'll
go personal they'll go personal they're
like oh let me let me bring up her
ex-boyfriend let's let's look at this
that's why she's doing they start to
like psychoanalyze you but it's like
it's what I said untrue
is what I said untrue work out but this
continued campaign means you're not
working on yourself the internet lasts
forever and someday you're probably
gonna have a chubby child who's gonna
see my oh hell no oh hell no I won't
have a chubby child look at that that
baby could be chubby when it's a baby
maybe toddler but I swear to God if your
child is fat that's on the parents and I
could argue as far as that is child
abuse if your child is morbidly obese as
a parent that's on you you control what
goes into that kid's mouth stop it stop
it having a chubby child is a choice
these videos
do better
accept that relationship is over but the
world didn't hurt you but you're
definitely trying to hoard a portion of
the world
guys thank you for watching I
ideas because I am convinced these
people are obsessed with me and they
actually love me because I think that
hey is closer to love and they're making
all these videos about me so I'm like
I'm important enough for you to make
videos about I I think it gases me up a
little bit so
um make sure you like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel ring
that notification Bell and I'll talk to
you next time as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible